the movie opens with the main character
Jake Sully narrating his simple and
peaceful life with his family in Pandora
as the chief of the umatakaya tribe he
mentions that he and his wife natiri
have a total of five children now two
sons netayam and loac a daughter Tak
their adopted daughter Kiri and a human
boy named spider Jake goes on to clarify
the Kiri is the daughter of his dear
friend Grace who died while helping the
navi people fight against humans as for
spider he was left behind when all the
humans returned to Earth after losing
their battle Jake states that the
children play together and take good
care of one another despite being
different in color and body size Jack
mentions that all of the children live
together like a family however natiri
does not like spider because he is
revealed to be the son of Colonel Miles
quarrich the evil man who almost wiped
off the navis it turns out that spider
was left behind on Pandora because he
was too small to be transported back to
Earth as he says you can't put babies
into Cry of sleep Kiri on the other hand
has special connection with spider and
is really fond of him as the Human boy
has spent all of his life with the navi
people he thinks that he is one of them
one night when nateri and Jack are
talking they noticed some bright
spaceships in the sky suddenly the
spaceships approached them and start
wreaking havoc the omotakaya habitat is
torched with flame resulting in
widespread destruction and deaths of
many animals from the spaceships a group
of soldiers with robotic artillery
emerge and finish off whatever else is
left of the place natiri and Jake who
are watching from afar are shocked to
learn that it is an RDA spaceship
carrying humans who are there to
colonize Pandora and build another main
operating station the scene then shifts
to one of the human Laboratories where
scientists have successfully created a
navi clone of the kernel he has been fed
with the memories and data that were
collected prior to his death because of
this the Colonel's clone knows
everything except who killed him and how
along with the colonel the scientists
have also manufactured the Clones of
other soldiers who were present during
their previous attack on Pandora as a
result the colonel and his men are
hell-bent on destroying the omotakaya
and in particular Jake meanwhile in an
attempt to ward off Intruders Jake leads
a navi Army towards the RDA train supply
lines he successfully infiltrates it and
manages to steal ammunition and Food
Supplies during this operation one of
his sons Loach does not listen to his
orders and gets himself wounded Jake
scolds him and asks him to be more
disciplined from here on out on the
other hand the colonel meets his senior
General Ardmore who informs him about
the Navy's flying Partners called
scounds they are currently attacking
their helicopters and slowing them down
hearing this kwarich makes a master plan
to invade the forest where they battled
previously and gather some information
about them soon he arrives at the forest
along with his other companions
unfortunately Jake's children are also
playing around in the same Forest right
then the colonel looks around the
previous Battlefield and discovers his
robotic suit with his remain remains
still inside all of this is observed by
loac and he immediately contacts his
father with the help of a voice
transmitter around his neck Jake listens
to this and suggests that loax stay away
from them and leave the place quietly he
and natiri then fly toward the forest to
check on their children's safety sadly
when loac and his siblings try to flee
they are captured by the humans the
colonel takes a closer look at their
fingers and gets to know that they are
his archrival's children just then
natiri and Jake arrive there and attack
the soldiers they managed to free most
of their children but not spider the
boys unfortunately taken away by the
evil humans later when the colonel asks
spider his name he quickly understands
that he is his son back in omotakaya
Jake approaches his wife and suggests
that they leave the place and head
towards the Eastern Seaboard he is
worried about spider revealing their
location to the colonel and his people
Jake also tells natiri that until he is
there with the tribe the humans will
keep attacking them as he is the one who
killed colonel korich in the first place
Nate Terry doesn't want to leave her
beautiful home but she knows that
whatever her husband is saying is true
hence she agrees to migrate with him on
the other hand General Ardmore dishes as
some cruelty on Spider by placing him in
a rotating machine yes put him in the
little naked human spinny machine
that'll make him talk he tries to
extract important information from the
boy but to no avail spider is too loyal
to his Navi parents and he just won't
budge surprisingly the colonel cannot
see his son in this state so he
immediately stops the spinning machine
he then approaches the general and tells
her that he will handle spider in his
own way later he meets the boy in a
separate room and reassures him that
he's not a bad person he also discloses
that he's here to take him back to Earth
this warms up spider's heart and he
eventually agrees to provide him with
the information he wants in the next
scene Jake and his entire family leave
their native home and fly away on their
Scouts after flying for a few days they
finally arrive at a place called
metcaina where another Navi tribe lives
surprisingly the navi is living here are
fainter in color and they prefer to stay
in the water seeing Jake and his gang
they start making fun of their
appearance soon the head of the tribe
tonawari arrives with his wife he feels
skeptical about Jake and his family and
mentions that they are not suited to
survive in the water however desperate
to save his family Jake promises that
they will adapt to the place in no time
he then reveals how they are being
chased after by some humans hearing this
tonawari finally agrees to let them stay
and provides them with shelter he also
asks his children to teach Jake's
children how to swim and use their
special creatures to move around the
water obliging to the request tonaware's
children take their new friends to the
ocean and start showing them the basics
meanwhile the ever so mischievous lohack
tries to connect with a sea creature but
loses control and falls into the water
seeing him tonawari's children start
laughing as all this is happening the
girl Kiri can be seen deep inside the
ocean surprisingly she has adapted well
to the place and can even control some
sea creatures mysterious and convenient
the following day while Kiri is
meditating underwater tonawari's son
ayanang and his friends approach her and
start making fun of her calling her a
freak because of this loac arrives and
punches anang anang doesn't take this
sitting down though and starts clapping
some ass with his tick tail later when
Jake finds out about the incident he
angrily orders his son to go and
apologize to anang as he is the clan
Leader's son reluctantly lowak agrees
and says sorry although anang forgives
him in front of the others deep down he
is still angry so in order to teach low
adolescent he takes him to a scheduled
location on the pretext of swimming loac
is completely oblivious that there are
dangerous sea predators in the area a
while later when loac is fishing a large
Predator swims at him rapidly terrified
afraid Loach looks around for help but
fails to find anyone but just then a
humongous creature named payakan comes
to the rescue it swiftly kills the
Predator with the help of its wide head
here we get to know that payakan is a
tolkun a peaceful and intelligent
creature there are thousands of tulcans
in the sea which the metakaina regard as
their spiritual family pyacan is the
largest and mightiest of them all in the
meantime loak is rescued and brought to
the surface by pyacan the latter also
helps the creature by pulling out some
harpoons which were apparently hurting
it with this the two create a beautiful
Bond and befriend each other lohack even
climbs through his blowhole it's
disgusting later when loac reaches land
he is called up by tonawari the strict
leader is found out about his son's
Shenanigans and wants anong to apologize
however this selfless low act accepts
responsibility for his actions and lies
that anang had nothing to do with it
this finally makes anang understand that
the new navies are not so bad after all
after some time lowack reunites with his
brother and friends and explains how
payakon saved his life to his surprise
No One Believes him instead they reveal
that payakon is a killer and that's why
it was abandoned by the other toolkoons
on the other hand spider briefs the
kernel about some Navi culture and takes
him to the Hallelujah mountains to
select a scound for him at first the
colonel struggles but soon he gets the
hang of it and flies her out shortly
after he also gets information about
Jake's possible location and heads
towards the metcaina reef with his army
on arriving he confronts some of the
Zoras and inquires if they know Jake
when the Navies say no the evil humans
kill one of them and also burn their
houses despite this The navis Stand by
their statement left with no options the
colonel signals his team to go for Plan
B now he wants to kill the tool guns in
large numbers hoping that this will
finally draw out Jake but there is
another advantage to killing them the
tolkans have a precious liquid inside
their brains which can increase the
longevity of life on earth a single
leader of this liquid will go for
Millions space whale brain goop the only
resource more valuable than unobtainium
soon some hunters start chasing after
the sea monsters they strike numerous
trackers into them and render them
unconscious in a heartbreaking scene we
can see a mother tolkun brutally laid to
death while her Offspring Lays by her in
shock the humans eventually leave with
the trackers still inside the tolkuns
when the mechaina discovered that their
friends are getting killed they become
angry and decide to engage with the
attackers however Jake calms them down
and mentions that they need to inform
the tolkens about the trackers first
this is the only way that they can
prevent a future strike as soon as loac
hears this he leaves to inform his best
friend payakon about it ayanung and a
few other locals also join him after a
while they eventually meet pyacan and
prepare to pull the tracker out of him
but just then the colonel and his
hunting crew arrive in their whale ship
after seeing them loak connects to his
father and informs him about the
situation in the nick of time he and his
friends also managed to pull the tracker
out from payakon's body after this they
hide underwater while the Colonel's crew
starts looking for them meanwhile Jake
approaches tonawari and informs him that
their children are missing this worries
the last matter and he quickly orders
his people to prepare for war Jake and
natiri also grabbed their weapons and
soon all of them collectively head
towards the battlefield on the other
hand the colonel orders his crew to
launch their attack on the tool [ __ ]
and find Jake's children after searching
for a while they eventually find Kiri
and took and capture them in a net loak
tries his best to tear the net but gets
himself pulled to the whale ship with it
soon the colonel arrives and cuffs them
to the railing of the ship he then takes
lox color transmitter and asks Jake to
surrender for the safety of his children
having no options Jake agrees to his
conditions at the same time pyacan
notices his best friend Loach handcuffed
to the deck and he decides to save him
in a risky move he suddenly jumps onto
the deck and starts moving his massive
fins this throws away a lot of soldiers
and obliterates the ship taking
advantage of the distraction Jake and
the metakaina also launched their attack
on the colonel and his army they want to
save their children but they also want
revenge meanwhile spider breaks the
controller of the whale ship causing it
to strike the rocks and allow water to
fill inside it next Jake and his eldest
son nateam quickly climbed the deck and
free loak took and Kiri then they
ordered the children to return to safety
but Loach refuses instead he decides to
save his adopted brother's spider
netayim also joins him and after a bit
of searching they find Spider when they
are about to leave the ship the colonel
notices them and opens fire
unfortunately Nathan gets hit by one of
the bullets and is severely injured
Loach and spider immediately take him to
the shore to their mother but because of
the excessive blood loss he passes away
seeing her son die right in front of her
eyes nateiri starts crying and screaming
loudly meanwhile the evil Colonel
manages to capture kiry and Tuck using
his scound he later connects with Jake
and reveals that both his two daughters
are with him after getting this
information Jake somehow calms nathiri
down and persuades her to join him and
save their daughters the latter obliges
and filled with rage she calls her
scound grabs her bow and arrows and goes
flying towards the ship soon Jake
approaches the ship and causes an
explosion killing the Colonel's men
nateri also arrives there and starts
shooting arrows at the remaining humans
killing them all instantly meanwhile
Jake finds his little daughter took and
frees her but at the same time the
colonel also shows up he is holding Kiri
at knife point he threatens Jake to put
down his weapons and the latter
reluctantly does so in the meantime a
vengeful natiri captures spider and
threatens to kill him at first the
colonel mentions that he has no
relationship with spider but when natiri
makes a small cut in the boy's chest he
immediately leaves Kiri with this
nathiri and her family prepare to leave
but the colonel mentions that he will
again hunt Jake down and kill him later
Jake realizes that he needs to eliminate
the colonel to live a peaceful life
hence he returns to the battlefield this
time the archrivals fight each other in
an old-fashioned fist fight it is a
brutal one and the two match each other
stride for stride but in the end it is
our hero Jake who prevails he manages to
wrap his arms around the Colonel's neck
and knock him unconscious Jake assumes
that he is dead and lets him drown in
the water unfortunately he too struggles
to breathe and starts sinking to the
bottom but at the same time loac comes
to his rescue and brings him to the
surface later pyacan carries the whole
family and brings them to the shore on
the other hand spider also pulls his
biological dad out of the water and
saves his life but when the colonel asks
him to leave the place with him spider
refuses and returns to his adoptive
family in the last scene Jake's family
and the whole metakaina tribe bury
natayam's body at the bottom of the
ocean where the lighting tubes Embrace
him like their own the movie ends with
Jake remembering the best memories of
his Elder son and realizing that he is
in heaven with their gods subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching